[Musique]
verdun serait donc devenu le onzième
quartier le plus cool du monde bien
particulier d'abord c'est sa position
sur l'île c'est un arrondissement qui
est enclavée puis qui est un peu à
l'extérieur je vous dirais des routes de
transit régulière donc moi je me plais à
dire qu'on ne passe pas par verdun mais
on vient à verdon amanda ne va pas le
contredire
quand elle est arrivée il ya trois ans
on lui avait dit tu vas voir verdun
ville de montréal je savais qu une des
grosses attentes mais je trouve ça
vraiment très à coeur comme cartier cet
atelier boutique café
c'est le reflet du nouveau verdun des
artisans qui façonnent un autre visage
au quartier la piétonnisation wellington
cet été il serait aussi pour quelque
chose
sincèrement on a donné une bouffée
d'oxygène excessivement importante
fondamentale aux restaurateurs de la rue
avec un accès unique aux fleuves
le maire sait que son arrondissement a
le potentiel de rayonner on a misé
beaucoup la culture les événements
culturels à verdun entre des commerces
dynamiques une vie culturelle une plage
alors tout est rose un ver dans ses
sorties cellphone là est dans une
quartier cool et c'est d'avoir plus de
choix par rapport au restaurant tout ça
mais je pense que le problème c'est
vraiment c'est pourqui 1380 dollars en
moyenne pour un quatre et demi dans le
centre de berlin
impossible pour elle tous ses effets
pervers ne touche plus n'impacte plus
uniquement que les gens démunis
défavorisés
mais aussi touche de plus en plus la
classe moyenne le maire ne veut pas
s'ingérer dans le libre marché
mais il croit tout le monde quoi qu'est
la mixte et c'est ce qui fait le charme
et finalement l'ingrédient qui a
peut-être changé les choses en 2015
c'est diego qui met le doigt dessus mais
ici ma tu postes radio canada verdun